la séance est ouverte
nous avons le plaisir faire collègues de
recevoir aujourd'hui monsieur monbourg
en féministe monsieur le ministre de
vous êtes rendu disponible rapidement
pour répondre à nos questions pour
partager avec vous votre expérience
ministérielle votre responsable de
dirigeants politiques d'une grande
administration est un grand ministère
français pour comprendre dans le cadre
de notre commission les enjeux
d'ingérence les tentatives ou les
réalités
d'ingérence étrangère sur notre
évidemment pour votre domaine de
compétences sur nos entreprises sur
notre recherche sur notre brevet bref
sur tout ce qu'il y a de la valeur dans
le de ce qu'a permis d'accumuler le
travail et le génie des Françaises et
des Français
cette audition monsieur ministre
constituera en quelque sorte un volet
complémentaire à l'audition que vous
avez réalisé dans le cadre de la
commission d'enquête parlementaire sur
la pète de souveraineté énergétique de
la France vous aviez soulevé des points
qui avaient assisté qui m'avait
interpellé et j'estimé que dans le cadre
de travaux votre expérience était non
seulement intéressante il me semble
essentiel à la compréhension des enjeux
notamment je ne vous qu'à faire monsieur
ministre que dans le cadre de nos
commissions qui n'étaient pas à huis
clos à savoir le parquet national
financier lors de l'exposé préliminaire
du parquet national financier ils
avaient choisi sans que on leur demande
de quoi que ce soit d'accès leur
présentation leur travail leur
présentation de leur travail contre les
ingérences sur les enjeux de droit
extra-territorial américain en
particulier sur évidemment notre domaine
économique et notre industrie et donc il
m'a semblé essentiel compte tenu de ce
témoignage du parc national financier de
vous entendre en complément si le
parquet national financier n'avait pas
fait peut-être le dire tout transparence
peut-être que nous n'aurions pas fait
puisque ça orienté évidemment nos
travaux d'une manière différente nous
avons aussi auditionné la semaine
dernière Monsieur Michel Sapin enseigne
ministre
des Finances qui a été ministre à deux
reprises à Bercy et qui nous a partagé
aussi une analyse et une expérience
particulièrement intéressante notamment
dans le cadre le hasard ou la vie a
voulu que Monsieur sapin et deloit la
loi Sapa 1 et la loi Sapa 2 qui a donné
un cadre d'une part à la protection de
notre démocratie contre les ingérences
économiques financières et étrangères
dans les années 90 puis
sous le mandat de François Hollande une
protection une réaction enfin en tout
cas l'analyse peut-être que j'en fais
contre les ingérences américaines et
peut-être que vous aurez enfin pas
peut-être sans doute aurez-vous une
analyse à partager avec nous à ce sujet
nous sommes donc très honorés
d'être d'avoir votre présence
aujourd'hui je le précise monsieur le
ministre s'est audition et retransmise
en direct sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale l'enregistrement vidéo sera
ensuite disponible à la demande pour
ceux qui voudraient avoir en connaître
vous aurez monsieur le ministre la
parole pour une quinzaine de minutes ou
si vous souhaitez davantage n'hésitez
pas évidemment puis de poursuivons nos
échanges avec des questions de votre
serviteur des questions de Madame la
rapporteur qui nous rejoindra et des
membres de la commission je vous
rappelle monsieur ministre co selon
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires les
personnes auditionnées par la commission
d'enquête parlementaire doivent traiter
serment de dire la vérité toute la
vérité rien que la vérité aussi monsieur
le ministre je vous demande de lever la
main droite et de dire je le jure
je vous remercie et je vous laisse la
parole pour votre exposé préliminaire
bien monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés je vous remercie
de votre invitation
évident que le sujet est très large de
votre
enquête sur les ingérences multiples
ne permettront pas de répondre à tous
les sujets
néanmoins sur les ingérences économiques
et financières de puissance étrangères
je pense que
l'expérience que j'ai pu accumuler
lorsque j'étais en charge pendant entre
mai 2012 et août 2014 pourront je
l'espère servir à l'analyse de la
représentation nationale et tous ceux
qui voudront s'inspirer de vos travaux
il est vrai que nous sommes dans un état
de guerre économique mondiale on peut
peut-être trouver les mots excessifs
mais c'est exactement ce que nous
pouvons aujourd'hui constater le doux
commerce de Montesquieu et bien loin et
il est vrai que la première
mondialisation comme disait madame
Suzanne berger dans un très bon livre
assez fondateur d'ailleurs elle-même
professeur
omit à Harvard elle avait théorisé
qu'avant 1914 il y avait une première
mondialisation qui avait mené à la
confrontation des puissances
la bataille économique pour les matières
premières la bataille économique pour la
capture des marchés à conduit les
puissances à l'époque occidentale
européenne à s'affronter et donc nous
avons vécu un nouveau cycle de
mondialisation après
la naissance de l'OMC disons les choses
entre 1994 et 2001 l'entrée de la Chine
sans aucune contrepartie dans le
commerce mondial
un abaissement massif et généralisé des
droits de douane empêchant finalement
les nations
d'exercer ce qui leur restait de pouvoir
sur les échanges économiques et les
risques de concurrence déloyale
puis on résume d'ailleurs il y aurait
beaucoup pas dire sur les raisons de
cette mondialisation elle n'est pas
tombée du ciel elle n'est pas une donnée
économique ou technologique elle est un
fait d'abord politique car des
générations de dirigeants politiques ont
décidé qu'il en serait ainsi je renvoie
au livre d'un autre professeur américain
raoui abdelal qui dans son analyse de la
globalisation a expliqué comment était
né cet abaissement massif de droits de
douane qui a permis finalement et
autorisé une compétition encore plus
sauvage encore plus dur et qui ne sait
pas faite
au détriment de tous mais certainement
au détriment d'un pays comme la France
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas pour rien que
deux grands pays
occidentaux aujourd'hui dans les
enquêtes d'opinion grosso modo une
quinzaine d'années répondent toujours
négativement au bénéfice de la
mondialisation quand on les interroge il
y en a-t-il eu il y a eu les Etats-Unis
d'Amérique et la France ce sont deux
pays deux grands pays perdants dans
cette
dans cette révolution
juridico-politique qui est devenu une
révolution culturelle technologique et
économique
si oui pack M Parabellum disait les
Romains si vous voulez la paix préparez
la guerre nous ne sommes absolument pas
préparés à cette guerre et nous avons
aujourd'hui à vivre un certain nombre
d'ingérences économiques dans dans le
champ de nos entreprises je veux
rappeler quelques exemples qui
éclaireront finalement votre votre
commission donc
lorsque la France a décidé en 2003
c'était le président Chirac qui a pris
la décision d'exercer le véto au Conseil
de sécurité sur l'invasion par une
coalition occidentale
de l'Irak après les événements du 11
septembre 2001
les États-Unis d'Amérique qui
contrôlaient les catapultes qui
permettent leur image la pontage des
avions sur notre porte-avion avocat mais
il est tout à fait stratégique Charles
de Gaulle on fait l'objet d'un embargo
ni latéral comme mesure de rétorsion sur
la provisionnement d'un d'une pièce
stratégique qui était de facture
américaine et qui a fait l'objet d'un
embargo le général benteja s'est exprimé
à cette occasion il a dit nous avons été
obligés de mettre en maintenance pendant
entre 6 à 6 mois à un an le Charles de
Gaulle en raison des mesures de
rétorsion qui ont été prises par un État
étranger précisé supposément ami de la
France qui a décidé de nous mettre à
l'amende c'était donc une forme
d'ingérence et non respect
de l'opinion et de la position du
gouvernement français à l'époque voilà
un gouvernement qui dit non au Conseil
de sécurité selon les formes
à l'époque bon le narratif de cette
histoire est maintenant bien connu de la
représentation nationale et aussi du de
l'opinion publique
il se trouve que Gérard électrique a
racheté ce qu'on appelle l'îlot
conventionnel à la sortie des réacteurs
nucléaires de
bien sûr nos 58 réacteurs mais mais
aussi tous les autres ou sont équipés
qui sont équipés de la turbine dite
Arabel qui
assure la conversion de la vapeur en
électricité
et cette turbine Arabel qui a été
rachetée Alstom par Gérard électrique
c'est l'usine de Belfort qui est la
fabrique et la fabriquait
évidemment général électrique s'en est
servi pour exercer un chantage sur EDF
en demandant une augmentation
unilatérale des prix des pièces de
rechange et lorsque EDF a dit il n'en
est pas question alors que DF n'a pas
bougé le petit doigt lorsqu'ils étaient
agi de lutter contre le rachat d'Alstom
et bien qu'a fait général électrique
a fait une grève de la maintenance en
2016 pendant plusieurs mois ce sont des
faits qui sont aujourd'hui public et
connus et donc a fait pression sur EDF
Monsieur Lévy à l'époque président de DF
c'en était mûr une lettre expliquant que
ce n'est pas admissible entre
Jean courtois
on pourrait également évoquer et élargir
sur la question des ingérences
au métaux rares je vous renvoie
d'ailleurs aux travaux d'un
chercheur journaliste un peu les deux
enquêteurs et analyste monsieur
Guillaume Pitron qui a écrit un très bel
très beau livre sur la guerre des métaux
rares qu'il est actualisait je crois
depuis et que vous auriez intérêt à
entendre dans certains des détails qu'il
a été capable d'analyser
puisque les Chinois disposent du
contrôle de 44% si ma mémoire est bonne
des métaux rares qui permettent de
contrôler l'essentiel de l'industrie
actuelle
c'est 44% des métaux rares en vérité les
Chinois ont augmenté leur influence et
leur incidence sur les marchés
puisqu'ils font les prix des marchés et
donc sont en mesure aujourd'hui de faire
faire le yoyo ou le haut et les bas des
prix en faisant chuter artificiellement
les prix ou en les faisant monter
artificiellement pour obtenir la
maîtrise du marché quand ils font
baisser les prix ils mettent en faillite
les usines concurrentes c'est arrivé à
la France et une usine de magnésium dans
le sud de la France je crois en
Haute-Garonne qui a été fermé parce que
les prix mondiaux fixés
sous-influence chinois sur le marché
mondial sans aucune réaction des
autorités ni européennes ni française
bien sûr puisque le marché sacré dans
l'idéologie dominante et bien la
conséquence c'est que les mines ont
fermé qu'ensuite le magnésium a pu voir
son prix en raison de la rareté de la
pénurie dont s'était rendu maitre
le gouvernement chinois et ses outils
économiques ces entreprises qu'ils
contrôlent les prix ont pu remonter pris
auquel il était tout à fait rentable de
reprendre l'exploitation de l'usine
enfin de la de la de la mine de
magnésium je prends cet exemple
magnésium mais les Américains eux-mêmes
ont été victimes de ce type d'ingérence
par l'action sur le marché et des
mesures de dumping
prise pour faire fermer des mines
concurrentes puisque les grandes mines
de métaux rares ont été très souvent en
difficulté au bord de la faillite alors
les Allemands les Japonais ont pris des
décisions
visant à accepter de payer plus cher le
prix mais aucune mesure de sanction n'a
été prise contre les mesures
d'habils dumping mise en oeuvre par un
gouvernement qui agit par ingérence en
utilisant la croyance que les autres ou
dans le marché pour mettre en difficulté
les entreprises qui assurent
l'approvisionnement de leur industrie je
rappelle que qui contrôle
le minerai contrôle l'industrie je
rappelle aussi qu'il est tout à fait
probable que la Chine décide un moment
ou un autre détende les mesures
d'embargo de contrôle
d'approvisionnement donc d'exportation
pas seulement sur les terres comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui mais également sur
les produits semi transformés c'est à
les composants des batteries dont nous
sommes aujourd'hui dépendants
disposant ainsi la capacité de nous
vendre en quasi monopole leur propre
véhicule à batterie finie est terminée
et même équipant des véhicules donc nous
sommes attention
et c'est une alerte que je formule ces
ingérences sont monnaies courantes elles
ne subissent pas de réaction à la
hauteur de ce qu'il ce qu'elle
réclamerait alors après je veux aborder
un sujet qu'il a pour le coup après la
pratique
organise juridiquement la légalité avec
notre assentiment des de ce type
d'ingérence c'est les mécanismes en
matière défense nationale
guitare que nous
subissons ITAR et l'équivalent de ce que
nous avons nous sous la forme
d'autorisation d'exportation de matériel
de guerre
qui veut dire international trafic in
Arms regulation il y a sur la liste
fixée par l'administration américaine 20
000 références
il suffit d'un composant sur cette liste
de 20000
produits fabriqués made in USA fabriqués
aux États-Unis pour que l'administration
américaine non seulement puisse de façon
rétroactive sanctionnée une entreprise
qui aurait vendu sans son accord elle ne
si elle par hasard cela lui avait
échappé j'y reviendrai ensuite pour pour
aller un peu plus loin dans l'analyse du
de la nature des ingérences que nous
nous sommes en état de subir que nous
subissons aujourd'hui c'est que cette
liste dit tard aujourd'hui
permet non seulement de sanctionner les
violations
l'interdiction de vente ou de l'absence
d'autorisation de vente mais permet
parfois d'octroyer ou d'infliger des
mesures de blocage lorsqu'elles sont
connues a priori ou de d'infliger des
amendes extrêmement élevés pour non
respect de la demande d'autorisation
quelques exemples pour votre édification
personnelle nous avons été interdits de
vendre des rafales à l’égypte en 2018
parce que quelques composants figuraient
sur la liste des 20
000 composants Itard je rappelle qu'il y
a même des vernis des peintures qui
figurent sur la liste guitare j'ai
entendu la ministre de la Défense madame
Parly dire il y a peu je crois que
c'était il y a deux ou trois ans qu'il
s'agissait d'un processus rétroactif
extra-territoriale et intrusif et a
parfaitement raison mais la
désitarisation de notre économie
justifie donc qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a
un composant
que nous utilisons y compris pour nos
missiles MBDA par exemple qui a fait
l'objet de mesures ou Airbus
militaire matériel militaire fait
l'objet aussi de sanctions il y a une
amende en 2020 de 133 millions de
dollars quand même contrairement
militaire bon je militaire donc cette
déshytarisation devrait faire l'objet
d'un programme systématique de
relocalisation de la totalité pour que
nous ne soyons plus assujettis aux
ingérences permanentes l'administration
qui utilise des armes extraterritoriales
sur notre
sur notre industrie
alors évidemment on peut aller encore
plus loin dans la gradation des
ingérences et arriver aux fameux fine
correct practice Act FCPA qui a conduit
entre 2008 et 2017 alors c'est un texte
qui date qui est bien antérieur qui date
je crois des années 80
mais ce texte n'était pas utilisé
parce que les agences de renseignement
tels qu'elles existent aujourd'hui
d'abord parce qu'internet n'existait pas
et que les agences de renseignement
américains ne s'était pas mise à
exploiter les informations
sur le plan économique
la révélation
d'Edward Snowden
75 millions de conversations de mails
ont été exploités en France contre nous
c'est une ingérence
c'est-à-dire que le Président de la
République les ministres dans un temps
qu'on temporaire à la charge que
j'exerçais par exemple j'étais obligé
d'utiliser des téléphones cryptés parce
qu'on en a vu connaissance à l'époque
Snowden
donc ont été utilisés contre des grandes
entreprises et l'accentuation et
l'accélération des
poursuites orchestrées par le
Département Justice américain entre 2008
et 2017 26 entreprises condamnées il y a
quand même 21 qui ne sont pas
américaines donc on voit vers qui est
dirigé l'usage du FCPA mais quand on a
vu ce qui s'est passé dans la ferralstom
j'attire votre attention sur le fait je
l'ai dit devant la commission d'enquête
sur la souveraineté énergétique que
Monsieur Pierucci qui a été emprisonné
et qui a dû qui a perdu deux années de
sa vie en prison américaine on lui a mis
sous le nez
au mépris des règles de la prescription
des informations qui remontaient 10 ans
auparavant
il y avait un million de mails qui avait
été capturé
comment peut-on accepter que des
entreprises soient poursuivies et leurs
employés 10 ans après les faits sur la
foi d'un million de mails dont il
faudrait 3 années entières un cabinet
d'avocats pour les lire comment peut-on
accepter ce type d'ingérence
extraterritoriale car les États-Unis
d'Amérique n'étaient nullement
victime d'un quelconque préjudice ça ne
concernait ni une entreprise américaine
ça ne concernait pas le territoire
américain il s'agissait d'un
contrat entre l'Indonésie et Alstom
c'est une ingérence
dans notre
c'est une violation de notre
souveraineté c'est une ingérence dans la
vie de nos entreprises c'est une écoute
illégale face à laquelle les
protestations étaient faibles niveau
sonore et politique et diplomatique
et c'est une atteinte à nos intérêts
nationaux
alors là dessus je hausse légèrement le
ton pour essayer de faire comprendre la
représentation nationale et votre
commission d'enquête dont je remercie
quel serait unissent parce qu'elle donne
finalement l'occasion de faire le point
sur tous ces problèmes qui sont connus
bien sûr évidemment rien tout le monde
le sait mais quand on résume la
situation
on voit que si on ne fait rien nous
finirons couper en rondelles
et dans pas longtemps parce que ça va
très vite si vous regardez le nombre
d'entreprises françaises qui ont été
condamnées et qui ont été rachetés
derrière
vous avez déjà alors BNP il y a eu 9
milliards d'amende n'a pas été racheté
ça devait pas les intéresser
mais Alstom c'est une entreprise qui
était sous poursuite et sous menace
d'amende de 750 millions excusés du peu
qui était racheté il y a eu d'autres
exemples une visio quelques années
auparavant qu'ils aient l'objet de
poursuit de la part du deog qui a été
racheté par qui à votre avis général
électrique déjà
c'est une stratégie donc vous avez les
grandes entreprises américaines qui
travaillent avec le gouvernement
américain qui utilise le bras armé de la
justice lequel utilise les ressources de
renseignements des agences qui ont été
créés pour lutter contre le terrorisme
qui en fait
font autre chose que de
l'anti-terroriste
et on se laisse faire
c'est pour lesifications personnelles de
la représentation nationale je vous
donne ces éléments alors on pourrait
aller encore plus loin dans l'usage des
sanctions internationales contre l'Iran
par exemple nous avions 30% du marché
automobile avec Peugeot 30% du marché
iranien
monsieur Trump décide de dénoncer
uneilatéralement
l'accord de
l'arrangement qui avait eu entre les
puissances occidentales sur la question
du nucléaire et la République islamique
d'Iran
qu'avait obtenu Monsieur Obama et le
gouvernement français il y avait à
l'époque je m'en étais réjoui accordé
beaucoup d'efforts à cette alliance
enfin à cet accord qui n'était pas une
alliance mais qui était une forme de
limitation
des de l'investissement dans le
nucléaire civil par la République
islamique d'Iran donc cette dénonciation
unilatérale pour conséquence de remettre
à jour les sanctions internationales
contre toutes les entreprises qui
auraient eu la l'idée de commercial avec
l'Iran il se trouve que Peugeot
vendez 450 000 véhicules par an excusez
peu les assemblées sur place en Iran
évidemment les sanctions ont eu pour
conséquence que Peugeot a plié bagages
descend d'ailleurs le champ libre aux
entreprises américaines qui elles-mêmes
ont commencé à exporter vers l'Iran
donc on voit bien comment est utilisé de
façon perverse hypocrite faussement
vertueuse les règles internationales au
profit de la puissance alors attention
parce que j'ai lu quelque part
que
un FCPA chinois était en cours
d'élaboration donc nous allons nous
retrouver avec des lois
extra-territoriales dans ces conditions
là il ne reste plus qu'à
organiser notre
de manière à ce qu'elle s'annule
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire en
introduction je suis président madame la
rapporteur
donc nous avons nous-mêmes péchés par
naïveté et faiblesses nous ne sommes pas
équipés pour faire face aux intrusions
permanentes et nous subissons une
intensification des attaques contre nos
intérêts donc branle-bas de combat
voilà mon point de vue
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
cette exposé ma première question est
assez simple en tant que
communiste ministre du redressement
productif pardon et donc à la tête d'une
administration très conséquente en
France avec des services diversifiés
notamment une certaine services habilité
à travailler sur l'intelligence
économique pouvez-vous nous exposer des
a comment ça fonctionner comment ce
service d'intelligence économique
fonctionné comment il vous mettez au
courant la régularité est-ce que vous
aviez des réunions comment c'était
structuré en fait ou est-ce que
d'ailleurs ces services étaient
structurés est-ce qu'il vous rendez
compte régulièrement est-ce que entre le
moment vous avez pris vos fonctions et
le moment où vous avez dû les rendre
vous avez changé le mode de
fonctionnement de ce service bref un
état des lieux quand vous êtes
immunistre de nos services
d'intelligence économique
alors ce sont des services qui sont sous
l'autorité du Premier ministre
donc il est extrêmement difficile pour
un minitre futile de plein exercice de
demander une réforme du fonctionnement
d'un service du Premier ministre
c'est un service qui ne fonctionnait pas
puisque je n'ai eu aucune information et
que j'ai appris l'essentiel des attaques
qui nous étaient réservées dans la
presse c'est quand même ça l'histoire
et d'ailleurs lorsque moi j'avais des
besoins de renseignements pour des
raisons par exemple vous avez les
candidats à la reprise du jean un peu
stratégique qui vient de l'étranger
il y a pas grand monde qui se présente
on a des candidats un peu bizarres bon
bah on les fait scanner on les passe un
peu au rayons X pour savoir ce qu'ils
ont fait avant qui sont d'où ça sort où
et l'argent d'où il vient etc donc là on
avait à la demande j'avais
à disposition des services de
renseignement qui fonctionnent
économique et je veux saluer de ce point
de vue là
la direction des services extérieurs qui
fait ce travail
mais d'initiative absolument pas
voilà
alors est-ce que ça a changé c'était
extrêmement difficile parce que quand
vous n'avez pas autorité sur un service
vous ne pouvez pas lui demander
d'évoluer et pas autorité sur le
renseignement extérieur et lorsque j'ai
appelé un directeur des services
extérieurs dans l'enseignement extérieur
pour lui dire est-ce que vous savez que
nous sommes écoutés que nous sommes
rachetés à la découpe et que nous en
l'objet d'une attaque d'État il m'a dit
mais nous nous on fait pas la même chose
que donc c'est à dire il n'y avait pas
de réciprocité dans le dans la dans la
riposte bon pour des raisons que
j'ignore puisque cela relève des
procédures et des choix politiques qui
ont été établis par l'autorité
ministérielle interministériel en
l'occurrence président de la République
a pris des décisions sur les
orientations à donner
donner et attribuer à ses services et
qui m'échappait totalement donc ça toute
façon dans le fonctionnement de l'État
nous aurions intérêt à ce que ce qui est
interministériel sur l'intelligence
économique
mystère de l'économie soit associé alors
il faudrait que vous vous renseigner
parce que là je n'ai pas les
informations et que vous interrogiez les
acteurs sur la manière dont ça a évolué
depuis voilà moi je ne sais pas
merci Monsieur vouloir être redondant
avec ma question vous avez évoqué un
contexte particulier pendant vos
fonctions notamment effectivement
révélation sur un certain nombre
d'écoute
vous avez aussi exercé presque un an
entre le début de l'affaire Alstom que
vous avez donc appris
par la presse et le départ de vos
fonctions réalisant donc ces différents
éléments de contexte et sans doute
d'autres que vous n'avez pas le temps de
d'évoquer ici mes conduits exister
pendant pendant vos fonctions ce que
vous avez
nonobstore la suite qui a été donnée et
les changements qui ont été faits est-ce
que vous avez alerté notamment le
Premier ministre qui était en charge de
cela ce que vous avez semblé avoir une
écoute par rapport à ce dont vous
alertiez puisque
ce soit sous votre fonction dans les
mois qui ont succédé il est vrai qu'il y
a un nombre considérable pour pas dire
historique d'entreprises stratégiques
qui ont dans le capital nous a échappé
pour les nommer pour celles que j'ai en
tête
Lafarge
de mémoire il y a pas d'autres exemples
en tout cas dans un temps aussi réduit
et si là tout à fait et est-ce que vous
avez senti une réaction aussi bien des
ce qu'on appelle facilement pour les
grands corps ou en tout cas ceux qui
vont dire la permanence de l'État et de
veiller sur ses intérêts et de l'autre
côté ou de les décideurs politiques
alors les événements auxquels vous
faites allusion c'était à l'affaire
Alstom ce sont des roulés de mars 2014
je suis parti en août 2014 donc nous
avons consacré l'essentiel de cette
période à essayer de faire évoluer les
arbitrages nous avons pris le décret dit
du 14 mai 2014 dit Montebourg
je devrais pas dire ça parce qu'en fait
il a un nom très précis qui est le
contrôle des investissements étrangers
il a un nom un peu à rallonge mais on va
il est très très explicite puisque il
aurait permis
d'éviter ce qui s'est passé par la suite
technique qui est arrivé immédiatement
après
il y avait quand même la BPI et
l'Institut français du pétrole au sein
du conseil d'administration on aurait pu
voter contre
ce n'était pas le cas de Lafarge
ce n'était pas le cas d'Alcatel mais là
aussi on aurait pu je pense
bloqué
les sessions les transactions elles ne
l'ont pas été
ceux qui ont défendu la transaction
Lafarge c'est à dire les dirigeants ont
plaidé à ma connaissance
le maintien de l'ensemble des centres de
recherche du siège social sur le sol
français à chaque fois on nous vend le
maintien des fonctions productives de
recherche sur le sol national et à
chaque fois c'est le déménagement qui
qui se produit pourquoi parce que quand
on perd le centre de décision de toute
façon
les promesses engagent que ceux qui
veulent bien les croire
on nous vend une alliance en très haut
elle n'est jamais inexiste pas
d'alliance entrée
il y a des achats
et les alliances entre égaux c'est quand
on crée une entreprise ensemble ce qui
s'était passé avec
avec
la SNECMA général électrique sur les
moteurs d'avion en 1946 je crois ou 7
j'ai essayé de le faire sur les trois
coups entreprises d'Alstom pour limiter
les dégâts sur les énergies nouvelles
sur les réseaux et sur le nucléaire on
avait sur certaines 51% d'autres 49 et
on avait des possibilités de rachat
c'était une manière finalement de
préparer la suite et l'avenir en disant
pourra peut-être si ça tourne mal chez
Général Electric racheter ces trois
entreprises et reconstituer un Alstom
moderne et contemporain sur les grandes
fonctions énergétiques bon finalement
c'est co-entreprises ont été vendues par
mon successeur et surtout ça a mal
tourné pour Gérard électrique
qui aujourd'hui cherche à revendre et
qui si on avait gardé les trois
contre-entreprises aujourd'hui on
pourrait reconstituer un Alstom
donc bon vous voyez que l'avenir n'est
jamais écrit et que
l'économie est un sport de combat
alors donc pour vous répondre il n'y a
pas eu de réaction de cette nature pour
moi
souveniste mais nécessaire c'est-à-dire
où on a organisé en quelque sorte
l'administration autour de ça
l'administration d'abord elle n'a pas
d'autonomie l'obéit à son chef le chef
de l'administration c'est le ministre si
le ministre ne dit pas son
administration qu'il faut contrôler tous
les investissements étrangers et
surveiller tous les sujets pourquoi
voulez-vous qu'elle le fasse donc pour
moi la responsabilité revient à ceux qui
m'ont succédé et qui n'ont pas pris ces
décisions ils ont certainement des
raisons qu'il vous exposeront et moi je
les juge je juge que cette période
aurait pu être beaucoup plus efficace
pour la défense de nos intérêts
économiques nous n'en serions
certainement pas là si on avait utilisé
les outils qui sont sur la table et qui
fonctionnent
merci monsieur mes dernières questions
sur ce sujet puis après bon j'ai
énormément de questions à vous poser
mais je ferais passer la parole et je
reviendrai après sur mes autres
questions si elles n'ont pas été posées
quand vous arrivez
à Bercy
ainsi que le reste de gouvernement qui
aurait pu la connaître des dossiers que
vous payez traiter en interne en
interministériel est-ce que vous-même
avez été dans le respect évidemment du
secret défense et ça n'est pas de
réveiller des secrets mais dans la
manière
dont vous avez été accueillie à Bercy
est-ce que vous avez eu un mauvais
français à briefing sur sur ses enjeux
vous et votre cabinet d'ailleurs les
personnes qui étaient
vous ou votre cabinet qui était
susceptible aussi vous accompagner
pendant ces années d'avoir accès vous
alerter en tant que collaborateurs sur
un certain nombre de dossiers aucun être
humain personne ne peut tout savoir où
tout traiter évidemment c'est le c'est
le rôle d'un cabinet est-ce que donc
vous même avez été formé sur ces sujets
là alerter ce qu'on vous a aussi appris
je me souviens
je sais pas si vous étiez encore au
ministère madame flore Pellerin avait
été une petite polémique à l'époque mais
je crois que vous n'étiez plus ministre
sur le fait qu'elle n'utilisait pas son
téléphone crypté il y a vu un reportage
ou le téléphone crypté était caché était
sur un bureau encore dans son cellophane
ou assimilé et puis elle pouvait trouver
ça drôle de pas l'utiliser de d'utiliser
ces téléphones ordinaires alors que
estimer surtout pour la France que la
culture le patrimoine sont contraires un
enjeu de souveraineté et un enjeu
économique et commercial qui ne mérite
pas de second degré en tout cas
visiblement elle n'utilisait pas son
téléphone crypté contrairement à vous
que vous avez que vous avez mentionné ce
ce ce cet outil donc voilà tout
simplement est-ce que est-ce que
finalement les comportements que vous
avez eus dont l'utilisation de ce
téléphone crypté relève de votre éthique
personnelle de votre conviction de vos
convictions personnelles de votre
compréhension du monde tel que vous
l'avez exposé exposé régulièrement ou
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui est
où vous avez été alerté parce qu'il y a
une transmission d'information
transmission de dossier qui
vous vous comment dire vous mettez la
lumière sur ces enjeux
alors dans les transmissions il n'y a
pas ce type de considération néanmoins
mes directeurs de cabinets j'en ai eu
deux
ce sont préoccupés de ces questions là
et d'initiative ont organisé je crois
des réunions qui ont avec les personnes
sachantent ils m'ont rendu compte de ce
qu'il fallait faire je leur avais
demandé je les avais conforté dans cette
initiative mais c'est une initiative de
mes deux directeurs donc ça avait eu
lieu en effet et ils avaient des
rendez-vous réguliers avec
avec les services de renseignement
avec qui nous nous avions une
collaboration tout à fait fluide et
positif quand nous demandions les choses
nous avions mis en place un système de
de demande mais eux-mêmes ne se
sentaient pas mais c'était quelque chose
qui était
balbutiant c'était les débuts de
l'inquiétude finalement parce qu'on
voyait l'économie partir
à volo nous avions des dégâts
considérables sur les grandes et petites
entreprises donc on se posait évidemment
on avait une inquiétude
qui était sérieuse et donc tous les
moyens étaient bons pour défendre nos
intérêts c'est vrai alors peut-être que
tout cela aurait dû être amplifié mais
en tout cas ça reposait sur l'état
d'esprit de de musique
merci Monsieur ministre
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre bonjour et pardon pour le
retard que j'ai mis à rejoindre cette
commission d'enquête et qui m'a amené à
ne pas pouvoir être présente à
l'intégralité de votre propos
introductif je voulais simplement
rappeler y compris pour celles et ceux
qui regarderaient en direct ou qui
regarderont en différé cette audition
que effectivement au début des auditions
menées par notre commission d'enquête
nous avons auditionné tous les services
de l'État concernés de près loin par le
sujet qui nous préoccupe et qui ont à
connaître
du renseignement et de la protection des
intérêts français quel qu'il soit donc
il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup d'évolution
de la part de nos services qu'il soit
placé sous la direction du ministère des
armées sur la direction ministères de
l'Intérieur sous la direction du
ministère de l'Économie et
financer de la souveraineté des services
nouveaux d'ailleurs créés y compris à
l'intérieur de Bercy ce qu'on appelle le
Cissé des renforcements de compétences
et de prérogatives donner à un centre de
de service tous service du premier
cercle qui ont quand même commencé à je
dirais bâtir une armature assez robuste
en matière d'intelligence et
d'intelligence économique alors bien
évidemment cela est allé au fur et à
mesure que la perception de la menace et
du risque et était de plus en plus
prégnante bien bien évidemment mais
voilà je pense que c'était bon à
rappeler
on a vous avez vous même parlé du décret
Montebourg qui effectivement est un peu
entrer dans la postérité avec avec cette
appellation qu'on appelle enfin qui a
été assez renforcé transformé compléter
qu'ils appellent maintenant plutôt de
créer le maire mais enfin il y a une il
y a une continuité
santé stablement est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire quel regard vous portez sur
les renforcements et les compléments qui
ont été apportés dans la version
actuelle du décret le maire notamment à
la faveur mais pas que de la crise de la
crise sanitaire et est-ce que vous
estimez que dans sa rédaction actuelle
ce décret donc il concerne donc les les
investissements étrangers en France et
suffisamment protectrice
UGAR au nouveau enjeux et à
l'intensification d'un centre de menaces
qui pèse sur nos intérêts économiques
français
écoutez moi je juge que ce décret ça a
été très bien renforcé puisque
maintenant il est étendu je crois en
biotechnologies à la robotique et à
d'autres secteurs j'ai envie de vous
dire que le sujet n'est pas tant
l'écriture du décret que tout à fait
clair et net mais plutôt son absence
d'usage je préférerais qu'on l'utilise
régulièrement d'ailleurs sans sans qu'on
en fasse état on n'est pas obligé de
le dire
de le créer sur les toits mais
il serait utile que on en fasse un peu
plus usage alors j'ai déploré qu'on les
utilisés pour défendre Carrefour qui
n'étaient nullement menacés ne menacé
pas la souveraineté que un dépanneur
québécois comme Couche-Tard puisse le
racheter ou intervenir au capital je
considère pas que les Québécois les
parties avec les supermarchés et
Carrefour sous le bras il n'y avait
aucun risque et je ne pense d'ailleurs
pas que
c'était leur intention ni leurs désirs
d'autant que les Canadiens n'ont pas une
vision
impériale de la nature de celle qui
exerce soit les États-Unis soit la Chine
ce n'est pas ils n'ont pas un
comportement d'Empire ils ont un
comportement de nation humble comme le
nôtre donc nous pouvons nous entendre
avec les Canadiens culturellement nous
avons des valeurs assez assez communes
je dirais que s'agissant de la de la du
décret il y a l'état de petites
entreprises enfin un nombre important de
petites entreprises qui passent sous le
radar et qui sont tout à fait critiques
puisque elles vont peu à peu si nous les
laissons être rachetés
nourrir elles vont nourrir la liste de
litard
je prends l'exemple de la faire de
l'entreprise second il se trouve que
j'ai noué une alliance à titre
entrepreneuriale et personnelle avec un
fond qui s'appelle authium capital un
milliard 200 millions sous gestion nous
avons fait la proposition de racheter
cette entreprise qui fabrique des
robinets pour nos sous-marins nucléaires
et nos centrales nucléaires civils et
militaires ces pièces sont tout à fait
importante puisqu'elles concernent
l'intérieur des réacteurs
nous avons fait une offre de rachat
parce que Bercy se demandait qui allait
pouvoir acheter cette entreprise qui
fait l'objet d'une OPA sur la maison
mère qui est canadienne qui s'appelle
volant de la part d'une entreprise
transnationale américaine qui est côté à
la Bourse de New York qui s'appelle
flots servent Corporation je suis rendu
public ce matin la lettre que j'ai
adressée à Monsieur le ministre Bruno Le
Maire pour qu'il prenne des décisions
les décisions pour moi sur cette
robinetterie critique c'est qu'il est
impensable que
cette entreprise tombe dans le champ du
droit américain en raison du Patriote
Act qui permet à l'administration
américaine sans aucun contrôle sans
aucune autorisation judiciaire de poser
toutes sortes de questions à une
entreprise qui a suggestion droit
américain c'est-à-dire qui concerne des
secrets de fabrication pour nos
bâtiments militaires première
considération c'est un point stratégique
donc si le Gouvernement considère qui a
pas de risque moi je considère qu'il y
en a deux
nous ne pouvons pas laisser s'agrandir
la liste de litarisation de nos
de nos pièces critiques et notamment les
robinets s'ils sont Canadiens ils sont
pas sur la liste itea s'ils sont
américains sont sur la liste titar et
ces robinets mais c'est très simple le
gouvernement américain pourra nous
voilà on a déjà eu quelques précédents
dans l'affaire australienne donc nous
sommes nous ne sommes pas en situation
de courtoisie avec nos amis américains
nous avons des intérêts nationaux à
défense donc je demande devant votre
commission et j'aimerais vous en parler
si si d'ailleurs nous présentons une
candidature au rachat et nous aurons une
négociation de marché donc s'il y a
d'autres candidats français pour
reprendre ce goût que le meilleur gagne
nous ne demandons pas au ministère de
nous
d'obliger volant à nous vendre ce goût
nous demandons au ministère d'empêcher
l'OPA sur ce goût par par flossaire
Corporation ce qui est une décision j'ai
demandé à Monsieur le Ministre le maire
de prendre l'usage du décret du 14 mai
2014 qui porte son nom maintenant
d'autant qu'il est ministre de la
souveraineté industrielle
c'est le moment
de le montrer
il se trouve qu'à ce sujet cet
après-midi même lors de la séance des
questions au Gouvernement madame Olivia
Grégoire qui remplacait Bruno Le Maire
en déplacement avec le chef de l'État a
eu l'occasion de répondre à une question
sur le dossier Sego et
tout simplement c'est de notoriété
publique maintenant puisque le compte
rendu a été publié et que les questions
d'actualité sont diffusées en direct la
ministre a eu l'occasion de dire de
réaffirmer à quel point le gouvernement
français sera extrêmement vigilant et
que bien évidemment
la procédure de contrôle des
investissements étrangers en France sera
appliqué voilà à partir pas d'aller plus
loin et ça n'est pas une commission
d'enquête parlementaire sur ce sujet
mais voilà je dirais que la publicité de
votre propre démarche mais de manière
générale
le projecteur braqué sur
cette entreprise
sont maintenant
aller assez loin
tout à fait sur sur ma première question
oui juste vous voulez revenir sur
l'application du décret le maire sur
l'affaire Carrefour Couche-Tard
qui a été diversement commenté c'est
vrai il y avait quand même
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui a
pu être compris un sujet de de
sécurisation de l'approvisionnement
alimentaire on est quand même dans une
période où les questions de de
sécurisation d'approvisionnement
alimentaire de souveraineté alimentaire
de possibilités pour nos compatriotes
d'accéder à en toute sécurité à une
diversité de produits avec également les
considérations de poids de chaque l'on
connaît sont devenus des considérations
très très importantes auxquelles un
gouvernement ne peut pas demeurer
vous permettrez une remarque madame la
rapporteur je ne pense pas que
la sécurité alimentaire soit en cause
dans la prise de contrôle d'une chaîne
de supermarché d'autant qu'elle n'a pas
le monopole qui a d'autres supermarchés
et que il ne s'agit que de la
distribution et non pas de la production
en revanche avoir laissé passer et
partir technique Lafarge
Alcatel Alstom et beaucoup d'autres me
paraît beaucoup plus problématique voilà
et c'est pourtant le même gouvernement
donc bon je veux pas polémiquer c'est
pas mon sujet ni ma responsabilité mais
bon on peut quand même regarder les
choses d'une autre manière c'est bien de
se réveiller mais le sujet doit être
pertinent et là quand il s'agit
technologique quand il s'agit de brevet
qu'il s'agit d'usine qu'il s'agit de
lieux de production qui s'agit de
savoir-faire qui ont été créés il y a 40
ans qui sont sur le territoire il a
fallu des générations pour les faire
pour les faire arriver à cette maturité
que sont des capacités d'exportation
mondiale de la puissance nationale qui
s'exprime la question nationale ce n'est
pas une affaire supermarché si une
affaire de technologie de brevets et de
puissance économique et industrielle
non j'entends cela tout à fait il y a
par ailleurs une commission d'enquête
présidée par Olivier Marleix dans le
rapporteur était Guillaume casse variant
qui mais vous avez je crois était
auditionné à l'époque la commission
d'enquête sur voilà tout à fait donc je
veux dire il y a eu non non pas du tout
excusez-moi monsieur
entre vous deux non mais voilà on a été
contre non mais juste voilà c'est ça il
y a un centre de préconisation et
beaucoup de choses qui ont été portées à
la connaissance du grand public à
travers l'excellent travail de la
commission d'enquête marlex gaz barian
dont nous n'avons pas vocation à
reprendre tous les tenants et
aboutissants puisque nous essayons de
braquer les projecteurs sur des champs
peut-être un peu moins dans la lumière
s'agissant des ingérences des
interférences et des influences qui sont
de plus en plus présentes dans les
débats politiques notamment et
informationnel je dirais de notre
démocratie
avant de laisser la parole aux
vice-président à une question que
m'inspire là la question que vous a posé
en tant que ministre et là je
m'intéresse vraiment à au dossier que
vous avez eu à connaître quand un enjeu
de rachat d'une entreprise stratégique
alors ce qui fait la une mais il y a
aussi vous en avez cité des entreprises
moins connues du grand public qui
peuvent jouer un rôle industriel clé et
même vital pour notre pays est-ce que
dans le cadre c'est pour ça que je vais
me permettre de poser ses exemples pour
recentrer effectivement comme l'alerte
le rapporteur sur nos travaux est-ce que
vous avez eu à faire
des influences
des tentatives d'ingérence pour chercher
à influencer votre position ou vos
suites de votre cabinet est-ce que vous
avez vu ce qu'on appelle des visiteurs
du soir ou du matin je ne sais pas
est-ce que vous avez eu à connaître de
comment dire de d'oeuf de lobby une fois
un peu bon de lobbying sous ses diverses
formes est-ce que
voilà en tant que ministre vous avez eu
à assister à des tentatives pour le coup
soit d'influence soit parfois
d'ingérence contre lesquels vous avez eu
à combattre vous avez eu à combattre en
tout cas observer
à titre personnel non peut-être que mon
équipe à l'époque qui reçoit parce que
je leur demandais qui recevait plutôt
systématiquement un genre demandé de
recevoir les demandes ont pu avoir cette
sensation alors je n'ai pas pu faire un
tour d'horizon de mes principaux
collaborateurs mais
ils avaient des consignes extrêmement
strictes de prudence
et je dois dire que comme nous
collégialisons l'ensemble des décisions
à l'époque avec mon équipe
les choses étaient tout de suite compris
si elle pouvait être suspecte alors je
dois vous dire que
je n'ai pas eu j'ai dû faire un article
40 une fois
tu transmis au procureur un cas
puisque une autorité constituée qui
constate un délit à le devoir dans
l'avertir le procureur de la République
compétent donc ça m'est arrivé une fois
j'ai fait un article 40
au procureur concerné voilà ce n'était
pas un cas
dont j'avais été témoin mais on m'avait
rapporté un certain nombre d'éléments de
de
qui était des infractions pénales
immédiatement transmis ce qui pour moi
est comment dire quand j'ai des
parlementaires je les fais aussi
même sans fonction d'enquête je l'ai
fait à l'issue donc de commission
d'enquête parlementaire lorsque j'étais
à votre place monsieur le Président est
une quinzaine d'années une vingtaine
d'années donc je crois que ça fait
partie je l'ai fait comme parlementaire
dans ma circonscription également
plusieurs reprises bon j'ai acquis cette
habitude parce que je crois que la loi
c'est le bien commun normalement donc
quand on voit une infraction on ne peut
pas fermer les yeux détourner le regard
voilà
et
ultime complément à ma question dans le
cas des arbitrages là je sors de cadre
de votre ministère et de votre
administration des dossiers que vous
avez eu arbitrer vous-même mais dans le
cadre des arbitrages politiques que vous
avez eu à connaître est-ce que vous avez
été informé ou ressenti ou alerté sur
des positions politiques qui pouvaient
être prises pour des raisons non pas
d'enjeux idéologique de de différences
d'appréciation politique d'un dossier
quel qu'il soit mais que des positions
politiques soit des décideurs politiques
soient de leur entourage soit des
administrations pouvaient être
orienté par autre chose que par des
ingériens ça sert à rien de tourne
autour du pot vous pouvez orienter par
des tentatives d'influence ou
d'ingérence étrangères
et pas se souvenir j'avais souvenir de
confrontation politique de débats
extrêmement difficiles sur les
orientations qu'il fallait prendre mais
je n'y voyais que de la sincérité de
part et d'autre et de conviction bien
ancrée avec le caractère qui qui va avec
donc c'était pour moi plutôt cette
difficulté là qu'il fallait il fallait
vaincre et convaincre et ce n'était pas
des forces occultes c'était une
conviction que j'avais en face de moi
donc c'est le plus difficile vous savez
merci Monsieur le vice-président
monsieur ministre merci beaucoup pour
vous expliquer
assez bien ce que ce que vous considérez
comme une ingérence économique en tout
cas le mécanismes que vous avez eu à
constater vous avez beaucoup parlé de
des Américains un tout petit peu de la
Chine je sais pas si c'était un cas
concret je voulais savoir que vous avez
parlé aussi de de la mine magnésium de
Marignac qui est chez moi Haute-Garonne
t'inquiété qui est toujours qui est
toujours physiquement mais et donc en
fait j'ai voulu savoir si en fait dans
le cas de vos fonctions parce que les
États-Unis à l'époque c'était peut-être
le sujet parce que c'était l'actualité
du moment mais est-ce que vous avez eu
connaissance de d'autres affaires ou
d'autres entreprises qui ont été
présentées à travers des mécanismes vous
avez décrit par des entreprises par des
entreprises étrangères autres que les
États-Unis
en fait j'ai orienté mon analyse sur une
expérience qui est celle à la fois
la confrontation avec deux empires qui
sont ceux qui structurent aujourd'hui
géopolitiquement
géo économiquement le paysage mondial
c'est-à-dire les États-Unis et la Chine
tous les autres sont en situation
semblable à ce qu'est la France
c'est-à-dire trop petit pour jouer un
rôle avec une Union européenne qui est
incapable de se hisser politiquement au
niveau des des menaces qui nous guettent
je dois vous dire que la question
numérique que j'ai peu aborder mais je
voudrais préciser à l'occasion de votre
question monsieur le vice-président je
vais vous remettre un document qui m'a
été remis par trois experts de
l'intelligence numérique je ne suis pas
en mesure de reprendre à mon compte les
explications de ces experts parce que
cela dépasse mes compétences mais
l'analyse qu'ils font extrêmement
inquiétante et ils m'ont prié lorsqu'ils
m'ont apporté ce document de le
transmettre aux autorités compétentes
et
il y a un salon de gens que vous la note
est signée donc vous pourrez interroger
dument les personnes concernées et je
vous la remettrai dans un instant et
donc l'essentiel aujourd'hui de la
menace elle est puisque nous sommes
devenus une colonie numérique des
États-Unis d'Amérique puisque les batx
Chinois n'entre pas encore chez nous
mais il pourrait le devenir
et d'ailleurs si nous n'avions pas pris
les mesures sur Huawei contre Huawei ce
qu'on fait les Américains et les
Européens peut-être ne n'en serions nous
pas là donc nous avons à faire à deux
grandes puissances qui veulent exercer
la puissance et si nul ne l'arrête
nous serons bientôt leur prochaine
victime nous n'avons pas
en France à
un état d'esprit prêt à accepter la
servitude je renvoie à
la Boétie il dit que c'est une question
c'est très intéressant le discours sur
le sur la servitude parce qu'ils disent
c'est comme une question d'habitude on
s'est habitué à ce que aujourd'hui il y
a un abus de position dominante sur les
moteurs de recherche Google mais vous
allez dans n'importe quel pays asiatique
il n'y a pas Google il y a des moteurs
de recherche
on s'est habitué à passer des accords
économiques avec Google Microsoft même
les armées sont là et donc nous avons à
sortir de cette habitude
du colonisé numérique voilà et ça je
dois vous dire que tous les autres pays
du monde qui n'ont pas la taille de ces
de ces grands empires sont en situation
assez proche de la nôtre s'il est
certain ont organisé leur défense nous
avons tous les moyens de le faire il
nous manque
le leadership politique pour l'assurer
et européen d'abord et puis nationale
également regardez le retard stratégique
que nous avons sur les moyens de défense
que nous aurions dû aligner depuis
longtemps je parle de fait qu'il y a 10
ans on en est à se demander sur une
boîte de 15 millions de chiffre
d'affaires six fois aller chercher le
décret du 2014 ça devrait être fait
automatiquement sans discussion
on est obligé d'en faire un débat
politique à l'Assemblée nationale
nous sommes en retard stratégiquement
monsieur
c'est pas c'est pas très grave parce que
oui non mais par exemple en termes de
d'ingérence on a eu avec d'autres
experts et peut-être pas dans le milieu
économique d'autres pays qui ont été
cités notamment l'Inde ou la Russie et
donc j'imagine que ces processus même si
non pas le caractère extra territorial
qu'on le droit américain il doit y avoir
des processus qui existent une tête qui
n'aurait pas eu connaissance par
ailleurs juste pour vous dire que
l'Europe ne fait pas rien puisque on
s'organise autour du DSA du DMA et que
une loi française va bientôt être portée
je peux pas vous en dévoiler les le
contenu parce que c'est quelque chose
qui se prépare qui va compléter
justement au niveau numérique la
protection et également aussi au niveau
de la défense voilà
sur les questions des commissaires sur
quand vous étiez ministre est-ce que
vous avez eu quand même connaissance ou
pas
d'une volonté peut-être de la Russie
notamment suite au mandat de Nicolas
Sarkozy ou les relations économiques
étaient on va dire
favorable sur un certain nombre
d'investissement qui ont été faits par
des grandes entreprises ou la vente par
exemple du contrat Mistral donc on avait
des mouvements économiques entre 2000 on
va dire le deuxième mandat de la Chirac
et panda Nicolas Sarkozy
d'investissement vers la Russie est-ce
que quand vous étiez mis vous avez eu à
connaître de ces investissements de la
France vers la Russie n'ont pas que ce
soit d'ingérence française en Russie
c'est pas l'objet de notre commission
mais est-ce que ces investissements à
votre connaissance aurait pu être et
peut-être que ça va prolongement de la
question du vice-président réalisé sous
influence ou sous un clairance russe
c'est-à-dire que des personnes avec de
l'influence ou un pouvoir de décision en
France aurait-elle plus favoriser ses
investissements français vers la Russie
et donc une ingérence dans des
arbitrages économiques français en
faveur de la Russie et aussi
même si effectivement dans les auditions
qu'on a pu faire on a pu être assuré sur
l'ingérence de ces pays mais ce que vous
avez des compléments d'information
là-dessus sur les pays du golf
notamment les différentes les
différentes monarchies pétrolières
est-ce que vous avez eu aussi à
connaître par exemple mandat précédent
il y avait une tentative de prise de
montée au capital d'Areva est-ce que
vous avez aussi connaissance de volonté
des fonds souverains ou de ou de fortune
personnelle ou institutionnelles liés au
monarchie du Golfe d'investir dans notre
pays où est-ce que vous n'avez pas eu
connaissance d'une telle volonté et j'ai
une question pardon excusez-moi pour
l'esprit d'escalier complémentaire sur
la Russie on a parlé d'exemple de
techniques est-ce que la Russie dans sa
volonté
d'accroître sa puissance son influence
ou la maîtrise de technologie dont elle
était dépendante de l'étranger a-t-elle
eu parfois la tentation pour ce que vous
avez à connaître d'investir en France
soit de prendre des départs soit par
exemple alors on peut très bien imaginer
que la Russie aurait que rosenf par
exemple aurait pu être intéressé par la
prise de contrôle de techniques pour
justement se passer d'une de compétences
étrangères dont elle a besoin encore
aujourd'hui pour exploiter ses propres
gisements
alors si c'est la Russie qui motivait
vos préoccupations je vais vous répondre
de façon tout à fait nette que à
l'époque nous avions une politique de
coopération très engagée avec la Russie
j'ai même été
accompagné le président de la République
de l'époque au Kremlin nous avons eu des
débats assez agités avec Monsieur
Poutine puisque nous avions des accords
de fond bien sûr mais cela restait
deux nations qui coopérait y compris
dans les secteurs qui étaient le mien
comme le nucléaire rosatum Areva
travaillait ensemble d'ailleurs j'ai
noté que cette coopération c'est
poursuivi aujourd'hui malgré les
événements
Ukrainiens puisque le nucléaire n'est
pas sous sanction actuellement donc
cette coopération était très importante
parce que ce n'est pas coopération
technologique et économique est-ce que
les ruches voulaient investir en France
c'est moi qui allait chercher parfois
lorsqu'il y a eu
la nécessité de pour moi à mes yeux de
nationaliser les hauts fourneaux de Flor
ange je fais le tour du monde
j'ai demandé à 10 ambassadeurs japonais
là où il y avait des des installations
industrielles
dans l'acideologie le Brésil
l'Italie la Russie
Canada Japon j'ai demandé à tous les
ambassadeurs où il y avait de
prendre contact avec
les sidérogistes en mesure d'être coin
investisseur à nos côtés dans la reprise
des hauts fourneaux de Florange que
mital Arcelor abandonnait
lâchement donc c'est moi qui et je me
souviens avoir eu une discussion avec un
industriel russe qui avait été candidat
malheureux face à mital Arcelor dans
l'OPA que mital Langlo indien avait
gagné quelques années plus tôt donc on
n'était pas du tout dans cette cette
univers c'était un univers purement
coopératif et tout à fait j'allais dire
amical avec la Russie à l'époque et même
si nos positions sur la Syrie étaient
extrêmement divergentes
elle n'empêchait pas que dans tous les
segments de l'action publique nous
étions
en coopération active j'ai le souvenir
d'ailleurs que
Monsieur Jean-Pierre Chevènement qui
était avait été nommé par le Président
de la République pour assurer en quelque
sorte le lien permanent entre les
autorités russes et les autorités
françaises comme Monsieur Raffarin avait
été nommé je crois à l'époque entre les
autorités chinoises les autorités
françaises et c'est avec eux que nous
avions des discussions d'opportunités
politiques mais il y avait d'abord je
crois un esprit politique
et les orientations
déterminaient le tout voilà je crois
avoir répondu mais c'était une autre
époque
et du Golfe nous avons eu je crois
nous avions eu à faire à un cas c'est
vrai vous me le rappelez c'est l'affaire
du kata et du fond sur les banlieues
auquel d'ailleurs j'avais décidé
de mettre fin parce que c'était un peu
curieux que une puissance étrangère
devait investir pour sauver
ou substituer l'État national des
faïence donc c'était absolument
inacceptable donc cette initiative a été
rabrouée
mais c'est le seul cas en effet auquel
c'est nous qui allions discuté avec
notamment les Émirats arabes unis
puisque nous avions une base militaire à
Abu Dhabi qui fonctionne d'ailleurs qui
est toujours installé donc vous avez une
coopération et d'ailleurs j'ai fait le
voyage officiel aux Émirats arabes unis
avec le président de la République où
nous avions des discussions bilatérales
avec les fonds d'investissement qui
eux-mêmes s'interroger sur l'économie
française est-elle en mesure
d'accueillir nos capitaux nous poser des
questions d'investisseurs étrangers en
France donc là aussi nous avons une
coopération active amicale même si nous
n'avions
Areva avait échoué à construire la
centrale nucléaire
des Émirats arabes unis nous avions
nous avions conservé évidemment
le désir de continuer cette coopération
merci monsieur dans le cadre vous avez
une question dans le cadre de ces
questions de relation économique pardon
avec la Russie alors c'était après votre
départ mais sans doute avez-vous comme
été mis au courant le réacteur
osirisa qui s'occupait de la production
d'un certain nombre de matières
radioactives destinées à usage médical
et fermer en définitivement en décembre
2015 après beaucoup de prolongement et
de mésaventures liées à la capacité au
retard ou grave retard qui c'est de
rester objectif pris sur la conception
et la construction de son successeur le
réacteur vu le rosbit
or est-ce que vous avez eu pendant votre
ministère à négocier notamment avec la
Russie la mise en place d'une de d'une
filière d'importation de ces isotopes
radioactifs à usage médical puisqu'en
court aujourd'hui nous avons une
confirmation de la ministre panier
ruinacés lors de la discussion sur le
projet de loi nucléaire la France est
aujourd'hui totalement dépendante de ces
présentation de matière pour le coup
vital pour notre pays puisque sans ces
matières nous ne pouvons pas utiliser un
certain nombre de d'éléments de
radiographie médicale mais aussi
d'utiliser la radiologie la radio pardon
la radiothérapie pour lutter contre le
cancer est-ce que cette ce sujet pour le
coup alors de
d'influence en tout cas de dépendance
économique a été évoqué quand vous étiez
ministre ou pas du tout ou alors ça
relève des pattes votre ministère
mais je dois vous dire que là je fais
travailler ma mémoire je suis incapable
de répondre néanmoins je l'interrogerai
autour de moi mes anciens collaborateurs
et je vous répondrai si vous me le
permettez de façon différée par écrit
parce que je n'ai pas le souvenir en
effet ce dossier me dit quelque chose
mais j'ai pas de souvenir précis si vous
m'aviez interrogé auparavant je serais
venu avec la documentation
je vous en prie je transmets très
évidemment votre réponse à l'ensemble
des commissaires une autre question sur
la gérance économique c'est sur les
relations avec les charmes de commerce
bilatérale
que ce soit donc comment en fait ma
question comment votre ministère
travaille avec ses chambres de commerce
réunissant les intérêts français
nationaux avec des partenaires
économiques dont on va parler des
patients enfin si vous pouvez peut-être
nous parler de ces relations pour les
principales puissances sur lesquels
c'est penché notre commission donc la
Russie qui dont les par exemple via le
comment s'appelle
le dialogue chorus donc qui a été conçu
avec des partenaires économiques mais
aussi l'âme Cham la Chambre de commerce
franco-américaine et s'il existe
d'autres chambres qui travaillent
là-dessus et comment on travaille avec
ça est-ce que pour vous c'est une
chambre de commerce relève de
l'influence
traditionnelle sous contrôle ou est-ce
que parfois ces champs pourraient être
pour être l'objet de tentative
d'ingérence notamment par exemple par
les liens privilégiés ou personnels qui
peuvent lire entre avec des intérêts
pour le coup économique avec des chefs
d'entreprise avec des dirigeants
d'entreprises avec des responsables de
filiales de grands groupes français ou
de secteurs juridiques directeur
comptable bref il existe un certain
nombre de rencontres est-ce que c'est ça
sont un peu quand même sous contrôle des
autorités françaises ou en tout cas sous
surveillance ou vigilance on va dire
écoutez je n'y vois pas ma liste dans
ces chambres de commerce dans mon
expérience je dois vous dire que c'est
un pour moi c'est un formidable vecteur
de promotion de notre pays c'est un
endroit où on reçoit la promotion
du pays
amis mais c'est aussi le moyen de faire
connaître le nôtre et c'est un moyen
aussi de de nouer des accords
d'entreprises entreprises donc je n'y
vois que des lieux de rencontre
dans mon expérience je me souviens de la
chambre de la Chambre de commerce Franco
saoudienne j'ai accueilli une délégation
complète de saoudiens à Chalon-sur-Saône
à Areva où ils ont visité les
installations d'Areva à un moment où
nous essayons de convaincre l’arabie
Saoudite de choisir le réacteur français
ce qui n'a finalement pas été le cas
mais j'ai le souvenir de d'année de
travail dans lequel la Chambre de
Commerce a fait beaucoup de beaucoup
d'efforts la Chambre de commerce ce sont
les amis des deux pays donc c'est un
point de rencontre et
utile pour le rayonnement notre pays
compris pour son exportation pour de ses
savoir-faire donc je n'y verrai aucune
aucune difficulté alors ce qui me
concerne d'autant que tout ça est tout à
fait transparent les ambassadeurs sont
tout le temps là les consuls aussi nos
diplomates font vivre ces enceintes les
échanges qui sont là sont toujours très
très diplomatiques très policés
et donc pour moi c'est un outil très
intéressant voilà je dirais comme ça
dans mon expérience
oui la réponse de Monsieur le Ministre
me fait juste souhaiter brièvement
prendre la parole monsieur le Président
et ce que vous avez dit sur les chambres
de commerce Franco une autre région du
monde voilà et tout à fait pertinent
bien évidemment et vous l'avez dit
vous-même il s'agit de structures
officielles qui sont adossées aux
réseaux consulaire avec lesquels nos
ambassades nos consulats les conseillers
du commerce extérieur etc sont en
relation et tout cela sont des
structures officielles qui travaillent
en tout temps transparence campignan sur
rue vous faisiez allusion monsieur le
Président à d'autres structures qui sont
plus quelquefois des Sénats ou des
officines ou la moindre des choses et
que le maître mot de transparence et et
et de sincérité dans la manière dont
s'organise les réunions les financements
le croisement des intérêts n'est pas
toujours aussi évident donc je garderai
bien de vouloir mêler voilà le réseau
des Chambres de Commerce officiel avec
d'autres types de structure vous avez
évoqué par exemple du dialogue
franco-rus qu'aux présidé par Thierry
Mariani on est là dans des registres
radicalement différents me semble-t-il
et où peuvent s'exercer clairement
plusieurs niveaux d'influence
d'interférences et d'un gérance
une question sur le cas que vous avez
évoqué de Monsieur Pierre outli
sans dans le respect évidemment de la
vie privée de Monsieur Frédéric pirouti
et du respect auquel il a le droit donc
monsieur a été arrêté en 2017
dans la commission de sur la
souveraineté économique vous savez été
vous avez indiqué de mémoire que vous
n'avez pas été informé de cette
arrestation et de ses conséquences
est-ce que à la lumière de cette
expérience vous avez une mentionné un
certain nombre de conditions de
détention évoquer c'est en tout cas le
livre l'ouvrage Monsieur Pierre outli
que ces conditions de détention avaient
l'air assez exorbitantes
par rapport à ce qui lui était reproché
est-ce que vous estimez que c'est un cas
unique
où est-ce que l'arrestation de
responsable d'entreprise qu'il s'agisse
en fait ce cas d'espèce mais est-ce que
déjà il y a eu d'autres exemples à votre
connaissance de responsable de cadre qui
sont arrêtés dans un pays étranger qui
soit dit d'une démocratie ou d'un régime
autor alors là permettant quand même la
défendre évidemment de l'État de droit à
l'autre non et donc ma question c'est
est-ce que c'est cette l'arrestation de
de cadre
est une forme
de pour influencer sur la politique soit
d'une grande multinationale qui a un
rôle dans le destin d'un pays ou d'une
autre en tout cas où est-ce que ça peut
être aussi une forme d'influence sur un
pays je crois qu'il y a eu des cas par
une arrestation de cadre au Japon de
japonais en Chine
et je crois aussi qu'il y a eu des cas
d'arrestation entre la Chine et les
États-Unis
alors je n'ai pas la recension des
des
arrestations pour des motifs économiques
on en connaît deux célèbres Monsieur
Pierre routier monsieur Carlos Ghosn
avec
les conséquences que l'on sait sur les
entreprises
un dirigeant arrêté l'entreprise
généralement
subit les conséquences néfastes de cette
de cette opération judiciaire
j'ai noté que
Monsieur Piotti avait été arrêté en 2000
je crois 14
et que nous avons été alertés non pas
par le consulat
alors que je crois le consul est allé
voir Monsieur ou la consul je sais plus
c'était un homme une femme d'aller voir
Monsieur perucci dans sa dans sa joue
mais il n'y a jamais eu de télégramme
diplomatique alors que je recevais un
nombre considérable de télégramme
diplomatique du monde entier sur des
questions économiques puisque il y a un
fil économique des TD et il n'y a pas eu
d'avertissement donc ça c'est un point
d'alerte
cercle réseau consulaire n'a pas fait
son travail voilà diplomatico consulaire
et je recevais je vous assure des
télégrammes sur des sujets
microscopiques aucun rapport qui était
assez éloigné de nos préoccupations
industrielle et économique alors ça
c'est un point important c'est à dire
que le réseau consulaire doit être en
état de veille permanente sur l'usage
qui est fait des des mesures d'ingérence
économique dans nos entreprises
ensuite votre question
concerne le
les cas d'autres cas je me souviens
quand même que Monsieur Perrucci on le
doit à son patriotisme auquel il faut
rendre hommage a été fait l'objet d'une
tentative en plus de la pression quand
il faisait l'objet c'est pour ça qu'il a
raison de parler de sorte de Tage de
prise d'otages légales en tout cas
juridiquement fondé
puisque en fait on faisait pression sur
lui pour qu'il
plaide coupable et entraîne avec lui
son entreprise et les autres dirigeants
ce qui semblait être fondée dans la
culpabilité de manière à pouvoir acheter
à la casse Alstom par derrière c'est ça
qui s'est produit et c'est ce qui s'est
produit
je dois vous dire que monsieur perucci a
refusé d'être embauché par
le procureur de Manhattan lui proposant
de participer à des séances d'écoute de
ses propres collègues où il devenait
agent judiciaire secret du département
of Justice des États-Unis d'Amérique
contre une entreprise française et
c'était ça le prix de son maintien en
liberté si j'ai bien compris
donc on est en droit quand même de de
se poser la question de savoir pour
quelle raison
là-dessus il n'y a pas eu de de
réactions diplomatiques sérieux
alors il se trouve que nous étions avec
le président de la République de
l'époque en voyage d'État Washington
voyage officiel ou la question Snowden a
été abordée d'une phrase dans la
conférence de presse conclusive des deux
chefs d'État sur Obama Monsieur Hollande
une phrase
je raconte ça dans le petit opuscule que
j'ai cru de voir faire pour que
on se souvienne de ces leçons à tirer de
cette période
je suis surpris de voir que cette
question n'a donné lieu à aucune
réaction d'ampleur alors qu'il
s'agissait d'une ingérence majeure dans
dans notre dans notre pays et notre
activité politique et économique
ça me paraît extrêmement grave ce qui
s'est passé à cette époque et nous ne
l'avons su que grâce à Monsieur schneden
Nous avons vu les conséquences à travers
la la le sort réservé à notre
compatriote monsieur Piotti
quand vous vous êtes en voyage avec le
président de la République et que vous
avez l'épisode que vous avez mentionné
dans cet ouvrage
de sa sortie d'une certaine couverture
qu'est-ce qu'on simplement on peut
s'attendre en tout cas je m'interroge et
qu'est-ce qu'on vous répond alors ça
évidemment comparé l'action d'ingérence
de puissance autoritaire hostile à notre
existence même mais dans le cadre de
l'alliance que nous avons avec les
États-Unis nos relations d'amitié
ce que vous avez parlé avec le président
de la République avec d'autres ministres
qui pouvaient impliqués Premier ministre
ministre de l'Intérieur ministre de la
défense
de la culture je maintiens que les
États-Unis ça les intéresse
est-ce que c'est un sujet auquel quand
vous êtes confronté à la réalité
factuelle du fait qu'il n'en parle pas
ce que qu'est-ce qu'on vous répond tout
simplement au sein du gouvernement sur
le fait que cette avait qualifié
vous-même c'est ingérence d'un allié
dans nos affaires qui par ailleurs n'est
pas que pour la France puisque ça a été
aussi élevé par votre de graves
ingérences dans un autre allié qui est
l'Allemagne par exemple il y en a
d'autres comment est-ce que vous
expliquez ce qu'on vous a donné des
enfin pas vous parce que vous avez donné
des pas mal d'explications mais est-ce
qu'on vous donne des explications est-ce
qu'on répond à vos questions ou est-ce
que on vous répond un silence poli comme
j'ai l'impression en tout cas dans le
dans l'ouvrage que vous avez publié
c'est le sentiment que j'ai eu
vous posez une question institutionnelle
finalement
comme vous le savez la diplomatie relève
du président de la République
et du mise à faire étrangères
subordonnée au président Premier
ministre pas dans ces considérations
en tout cas dans la répartition des
pouvoirs de cette hiérarchie instable
qu'est le couple président Premier
ministre
le président de la République a autorité
sur
la diplomatie et donc mène les
négociations de chef d'État chef d'État
ou chef de gouvernement chef d'État et
on ne peut pas dire qu'il n'en a pas
parlé
on peut dire juste qu'il en a peu parlé
voilà et que là et l'autre on trouvait
les conditions d'un arrangement mais
il est impossible d'interroger le
président de la République en lui
demandant des comptes sur son activité
diplomatique alors vous êtes lorsque
vous êtes ministre d'économie
tout simplement pourquoi parce que le
Président de la République rendait
compte à sa conscience
au peuple lorsqu'il veut bien soumettre
et à ceux à qui il veut bien parler de
ce qu'il fait mais lorsque vous êtes
ministre de l'économie ou ministre tout
court vous questionnez le président de
la République sur les arbitrages à venir
mais vous ne demandez pas des
comptes-rendus d'exécution sur ce qu'il
a fait ou mal fait ou bien fait pour une
raison simple c'est que cela appartient
à son autorité qui ne part pas
partageable c'est une question
institutionnelle
je vous parle des pratiques
et de la lecture des textes
institutionnel
oui
de pratique à côté des institutions
informelles des discussions d'omaomes
vous avez une vie vous les connaissez
avant vous les connaissez après c'était
ça aussi ma question c'est une très
bonne question mais vous avez des sujets
qui sont
auxquels on n'a pas de réponse voilà et
le temps de de cerveau disponible d'un
président à l'égard de féministe est
réservé à toutes les questions brûlantes
et non pas aux questions passées si on
passait bah il s'en débrouillera en
rendant des comptes devant le peuple
français s'il peut français un jour sans
l'aperçoit voilà mais en vérité c'est
très difficile de de d'obtenir du
président de la République des
explications sur ce qu'il fait ou ne
fait pas voilà et je dois vous dire que
dans le cadre
des questions économiques là pour le
coup et non pas
c'était déjà assez tumultueux et
difficile j'allais dire conflictuel
donc il était très difficile d'aborder
des sujets hors compétences
voilà ça c'est la réalité d'un
mais il est vrai que c'était un une
fonction enfin c'était une une période
assez difficile de coopération le
collège était assez divisé dans le
collège gouvernemental était assez
divisé à l'époque
merci Monsieur ma dernière question pour
ma part parce que moi je voudrais
revenir sur le cas de Monsieur pyroutli
quand vous avez eu connaissance de sa
situation et des implications j'imagine
que sa situation pouvait avoir sur
Alstom est-ce que vous avez absolument
la chercher à intervenir peut-être que
c'est public mais je l'ignore bonne foi
notamment je me souviens pour avoir été
moi-même en contact monsieur pieroutlic
un moment il est revenu il a une de
mémoire une condition une libération
conditionnelle avec je crois la mise en
la mise en cause du patrimoine d'amis
américain d'un certain montant il a pu
revenir en France voir sa famille et il
a dû ensuite repartir aux États-Unis
pour finir sa peine
pour honorer la promesse de pour ne pas
menacer pardon les biens de ses amis bon
compte tenu des relations
juridictionnelles avec entre la France
aux États-Unis il aurait pu rester en
France sans qu'on est à le croire à
l'extradé
il a fait que ce soit comme moi j'estime
courageux mais bon
ça ça n'applique que moi mais est-ce que
voilà à ce moment où il est venu en
France est-ce que
est-ce que vous l'avez rencontré est-ce
que vous allez chercher à comprendre la
situation à l'aider peut-être à proposer
une solution économique ou je ne sais
pas si c'est possible qui permette qui
reste et de compenser peut-être ses amis
bref est-ce que l'État français dans la
deuxième partie de sa peine a été au
rendez-vous ou pas
alors en effet il a ce qu'audié très
juste il est il est revenu après avoir
obtenu une libération conditionnelle il
m'avait expliqué mais je n'étais plus au
gouvernement à ce moment-là donc il est
venu me voir Tito privé alors pour me
remercier d'avoir appelé sa femme
essayer de trouver des solutions
quant à son quant à son sort et puis
surtout pour que nous nous confrontions
nos deux expériences moi au ministère
lui dans sa prison au sujet d'un même
d'une même entité qui s'appelait Alstom
et il m'a fait la narration de d'avoir
c'est vrai du emprunter et obtenir la
confiance de personnes qui ont prêté
l'équivalent d'une caution extrêmement
élevée je crois que plusieurs millions
et donc il souhaitait honorer son
engagement à la confiance qu'il qu'il
lui avait été faite de rembourser et
donc pour la restitution de la caution
la terminer sa peine il retourne aux
États-Unis c'est constitué prisonnier et
à l'époque
l'État n'était absolument pas présent à
ses côtés alors que
normalement aider un compatriotes dans
la difficulté sur une affaire comme
celle-là ou l'État aurait pu avoir une
autre politique et faire d'autres choix
je pense que c'était nécessaire mais je
crois que il n'a pas trouvé n'a pas
trouvé de soutien dans l'état à l'époque
un certain nombre de cas de Français qui
sont dans des procédures judiciaires
lourdes à l'étranger je pense à des
compatriotes qu'on peut être impliquer
dans des trafics de drogue dans
différentes trafics on Indonésie au
Mexique
qui ont été où l'État à toile travers la
voie consulaire soi-même à travers
parfois de gouvernement d'intervention
de gouvernement
chaque combat chacun de compassionne
évidemment a le droit de bénéficier de
la même protection de la nation et de
l'exercice des droits des droits de
l'homme de droits de l'homme évidemment
mais je peine à comprendre monsieur le
ministre comment dans ce cas d'espèces
même si au début il y a une une
défaillance consulaire sur sur votre
information la formation de gouvernement
comment compte tenu de la gravité une
fois plus de ce cas là c'est plus
quelque chose que l'État a oublié
par rapport je vous dis au trafic de
drogue au Mexique au trafic de drogue
Amazon
où est-ce que c'est ce que c'est de
votre point de vue vraiment une absence
une défaillance presque technique
politique ou est-ce que c'est une
volonté une volonté de ne pas intervenir
parce que
d'abord lorsque nous sommes aperçus du
sort qui était fait à Monsieur
pierreucci un de mes collaborateurs a
appelé son épouse qui était à Singapour
et celle-ci était elle-même terrorisée
par la pression qui exerçait l'État
américain sur son mari donc elle nous a
demandé surtout de ne pas intervenir car
il elle souhaitait que son mari organise
sa défense selon ses propres moyens pour
éviter la gravation de sa situation ce
que nous avons parfaitement compris
ensuite nous sommes arrivés au
dénouement de l'affaire Alstom
et je crois qu'ils espérait beaucoup de
se dénouement c'est-à-dire la vente
bon après je suis parti et lorsque j'ai
revu monsieur pierreucci qui est venu me
voir
il m'a expliqué qu'il était obligé de
repartir parce que l'État n'avait rien
fait généralement quand on a un
ressortissant qui est emprisonné à
l'étranger l'objectif de la politique de
de du Quai d'Orsay consiste à se
débrouiller pour que le dire
ressortissant exécute sa peine en France
mais là rien n'avait été fait en ce sens
ça a été fait après en fin de course
dans mes souvenirs il faudrait que vous
interroger monsieur perucci vous le
direz mieux que moi c'est son histoire
ça a été fait en fin de course lorsque
à la fin des fins avec son avocat qui
était venu me voir je pouvais l'aider
que je connaissais un peu parce que
j'avais été avocat dans ma jeunesse donc
je le connaissais et m'avait dit on va
réussir à obtenir le transfert pour
l'exécution de sa peine en France ce qui
a évidemment arrangé monsieur perottier
tout sa famille mais c'était une c'est
une très courte période par rapport à ce
qui restait exécuté de la peine donc ça
n'a été fait que sur le tard peut-être
tardivement mais je vous invite à
interroger monsieur perucci parce que
lui pourra vous dire exactement ce qu'il
en a été et quel niveau de contact il a
eu avec l'État comment ça s'est fait moi
j'étais plus en fonction ni en charge
et merci Monsieur ministre madame
rapporteur
monsieur vice-président ecoutez monsieur
le ministre vous remercie du temps que
vous avez consacré à notre cette
audition aux travaux de notre commission
réponse que vous avez apporté à nos à
nos différentes interrogations demande
de complément si vous souhaitez
effectivement apporter un complément par
écrit certaines questions évidemment
je les recevrai et je les transmettrai à
l'ensemble des commissaires une fois
encore monsieur ministre je vous
remercie je vous souhaite une bonne
soirée je vous remercie pour les
documents que vous avez souhaité nous
remettre sur le numérique
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
la remercie pardon les administrats
l'administration pour l'organisation la
préparation de cette séance et je te
souhaite une bonne soirée la séance est
levée